in the 1950s one of every two cars sold
in the u.s came from general motors
those were the glory days gm's market
share declined in the 80s and 90s before
it had to be bailed out by the us
government during the financial crisis
of 2009. out of the ashes emerged a
leaner company led by mary barra the
first woman to be ceo of a major
automaker now the home of chevrolet
cadillac gmc and buick faces another
test of survival the age of electric
tesla is by far the undisputed leader in
electric vehicles it delivered a record
309 000 evs in the fourth quarter of
2021 more than gm makes in an entire
year despite tesla's dominance president
joe baden praised gm ceo for leading the
world in electric vehicles you did mary
you electrified the entire automobile
industry i'm serious
you led
and it matters the numbers tell a
different story general motors only sold
26 electric vehicles in the u.s in the
fourth quarter of 2021. 25 chevy bolts
or the larger bolt euvs and one electric
hummer pickup tesla ceo elon musk chimed
in there's room for improvement the
reason for the abysmal numbers gm halted
sales of its bolts following a massive
recall due to the risk of batteries
spontaneously catching fire 2021 was
rough for gm its fourth quarter sales
fell 43 compared to a year earlier to
441 000 vehicles the company blamed the
global shortage of computer chips due to
the pandemic tesla on the other hand
managed the chip shortage by rewriting
its software to support alternative
chips tesla's ev market share in the u.s
is a commanding 66
gm's is around 10
despite tesla's massive ev lead gm
believes it can top tesla in sales as
barra told cnbc do you think that you
can catch tesla by 2025
absolutely phil when people get into
these vehicles they are just wowed so
we will be rolling them out and we're
going to just keep working until we have
number one market share in evs
gm is aiming for more than a million
global sales of evs by 2025 which tesla
has already achieved and it's looking to
grow even faster you know our goal as a
company here is to grow
on an average pace of 50 per year a 50
growth rate per year based on current
figures would have tesla easily surpass
its target of 20 million cars a year by
2030 bolstered by two additional
gigafactories that will soon come online
in austin texas and berlin meanwhile gm
is retooling half of its manufacturing
plants in the us and china to make them
capable of producing electric vehicles
by the end of the decade general motors
sells more electric cars in china
through its joint ventures than in the
us
and in one of the most ambitious moves
in the auto industry gm says it will
stop selling gasoline-powered vehicles
altogether by 2035. that is a complete
u-turn by a company that famously killed
its electric car the ev1 in the 90s by
crushing them in a junkyard a twist of
fate that led to tesla two engineers
disgusted by gm's actions founded tesla
motors in 2003. an all-electric future
is hard to imagine for a company that
has built an empire on fossil
fuel-powered vehicles as morgan stanley
analyst adam jones pointed out in his
interview with gm's ceo
but mary how do you exit a business
that today accounts for basically 100 of
your profit and cash flow how do you do
that well we've got 14 years you know
and i think when you look at the fact
that we'll have more than 30 vehicles
globally that are ev by
2025 we have aggressive plans after that
but time may not be on gm's side legacy
car companies have a tricky balancing
act as they phase out their old business
to make way for the new they have to
figure out how to keep their car
dealerships happy for example electric
vehicles require less maintenance as
they have fewer moving parts which could
result in a significant loss of revenue
for a dealer they don't require oil
changes and routine repairs that make up
as much as half a dealership's gross
profits and gm still has to figure out
how to make evs profitable batteries are
the priciest part of an electric car gm
says its new altium batteries will drive
down costs below a hundred dollars per
kilowatt hour the magic number that
would make electric cars roughly the
same price as combustion engine ones
tesla hasn't said what its battery price
target is but its 4680 battery cells are
considered pivotal in helping the
company reach its goal of selling a 25
000 tesla one day
there's a famous old saying about
general motors as goes gm so goes the
nation
implying that the company was so
powerful at one time that the country's
economic fortunes were tied to gm's
health that's clearly no longer the case
tesla's market cap of a trillion dollars
is 12 times higher than gm's what was
once the world's largest automaker is
now the underdog trying to chip away at
tesla's ev dominance electric cars are
clearly the way of the future there's
also another trend developing the wall
street journal reports art is among the
hottest markets on earth right now and
if you can't afford a monet or a picasso
there's another way to invest in fine
art through my sponsor masterworks
masterworks lets you buy shares in
multi-million dollar artworks just like
buying shares in tesla once masterwork
sells the art or you sell your shares on
their secondary market the rewards could
be enormous masterworks flipped banksy's
take on the mona lisa for a 32 return to
investors contemporary art has far
outpaced the s p in the last decade the
total wealth held in art is estimated to
be 1.7 trillion and deloitte projects it
to grow 900 billion by 2026. if you want
to diversify your portfolio especially
in today's bull market there's usually a
wait list to invest in fine art however
you can skip that wait list and
immediately start investing by clicking
my custom link in the description which
also helps to support my channel thanks
for watching for news think i'm cindy
palm
[Music]